quatre impacts de balles sur des litres
de l'accueil périscolaire de l'école au
lendemain de la découverte
les parents d'élèves sont inquiets des
enfants de maternelle et voilà il ya des
enfants il ya du personnel
donc on est quand même très inquiet je
pense que c'est grave oui il faut que
les institutions se mobilisent puisque
c'est quand même un quartier où il ya
beaucoup d'enfants et il faut absolument
que quelque chose soit fait par rapport
à cet état de fait 1 pour l'heure on ne
sait pas quelle arme a été utilisée
les parents d'élèves nous présente cette
cartouche qu'ils auraient retrouvé à
proximité
en marge de sa visite ministérielle à
dijon jean michel blanquer s'est rendu
sur les lieux
à chaque fois que il y à un incident de
ce type c'est important que les
professeurs sont le soutien
d'institutions et l'ensemble d'ailleurs
des personnes qui travaillent dans cette
école un cycle et que les parents
d'élèves et s'était notamment pour
manifester son soutien
la ville de dijon pour sa part a porté
plainte une enquête est actuellement en
cours pour tenter de retrouver le ou les
auteurs des tirs